welcome uh
to the press conference following the
informal leaders video conference on
covet coordination you might have seen
that we have published a statement on
behalf of the 27 leaders on our website
following the recent attacks in in
france
i invite you all to switch on your
cameras
and we turn to the president of the
european council please
thank you good evening everyone
first of all let me express our full
solidarity with france
and the people of france on the recent
terrorist attacks
i would like to express my deepest
condolences to the families
of the victims we stand together
the european family united for our
democratic values
and freedoms
liberty
the numbers are increasing everywhere
in europe our hospitals and health
workers
are again under pressure and that's why
many leaders have announced
lockdown and restrictions in such
hard times cohesion and solidarity
matter more than ever we call on
all the europeans to take care of
themselves
and of each other i thought tonight
first go to all those who are suffering
to the most vulnerable in our societies
to
all of them i want to express our
greatest sympathy
and convey our support a bit
a big thank you also to our medical
teams
that are doing an extraordinary job
in such difficult circumstances
today with the leaders during the video
conference we had the occasion to focus
on testing and tracing policies and
unvaccines
because those issues are crucial
not only in the short term but also in
the mid
and the longer term we shared our
experiences
and we discussed how to help each other
testing and tracing are key to limiting
the spread of the virus
it's crucial because it will allow us to
better control the situation
we exchanged on how to advance a common
approach
to the mutual recognition deployment and
use
of rapid tests this would reduce
the negative impact on free movement and
on the functioning of our single market
which we absolutely
need to preserve yesterday the
commission presented a recommendation on
testing strategies
and we will work actively on that basis
to strengthen
the coordination on tracing to encourage
all member states
to participate in this initiative on
interoperability between apps
put on the table by the commission and
another goal to facilitate stressing
is the establishment of a common
passenger locator form
on which we should continue to make
progress
we also had the occasion to discuss the
possibility of
harmonizing the duration of quarantine
for those infected with it
initiatives
is
um
to tackle an important topic the
economic recovery
and this is a clear a clear message we
hope that it will be possible in the
very short term
to to decide on the implementation
of the of the package that we have
agreed in
july because we we all understand
that it's very important to make
progress
in order to limit the spread of the
virus which is
a very important measure in order to
limit
the economic and the social damage but
it's also important to
implement what we have decided
to
thank you mr president madam president
merci beaucoup attack
audience a brutal denise mata
just took
this afternoon this evening we have
discussed indeed
the covet pandemic and how to proceed
i do not need to repeat in detail my
assessment of the health
situation because you heard it yesterday
during my press conference
i think it is enough to say that it is
very serious numbers of cases
are rising numbers of hospitalization
are rising numbers are of death
are rising not as fast
fortunately because we understand better
today
how to treat covet patients and how to
deal with the disease
but the spread of the virus will
overwhelm
our health care systems if we do not act
urgently
and it is important to act coherent
across the european union and therefore
this vtc was very helpful
so i had five messages for the leaders
today
the first one is on data sharing
we have to share comprehensive and
accurate
data in real time with the ecdc platform
this is of utmost importance and it is
in everyone's
interest because it helps us to know
what is going on to act coherently to
know better
about the actual situation and it helps
us to coordinate for example
if we have more data sharing on
icu capacity and where
capacity is lacking we can
increase the cross-border patient care
and it can be organized early enough
so the more countries share information
the better we can coordinate
the response the commission announced
tonight that we are making 220 million
euros
available to finance a safe cross-border
transfer of patients
where it is needed and for that the good
use of the money
requires good information in exchange
the second topic was also a topic on
sharing
but in this time in this case experience
and
analysis we will launch
a platform to bring together the
specialists
that are advising each national
government and the experts that are
advising the european union
it were national science advisor who
asked us to do this
in order to share best practice
and to align science advice to
governments
across the union we're learning by the
day
by the week and also science is learning
how to deal with this disease and
therefore
this exchange of scientific knowledge
on the highest level is of utmost
importance because this way
we will learn from each other what works
and we will avoid conflicting or
confusing messages
the third topic is testing
our goal is keeping the virus in check
and that goes through massive testing
so we agreed that we need to have quick
validation
at eu level of the new tests and this
refers
mainly to the rapid antigen tests that
are currently being developed
they certainly have an important role to
play
we have the pcr testing and we have the
new rapid antigen tests
we will work on the validation on eu
level
because this will then enable us to
describe the optimal setting for the
different
forms of tests and it will enable us
for a mutual recognition of test results
across the european union and that of
course is important
mainly when essential travel is taking
place
the fourth topic is tracing
so testing and tracing go hand in hand
22 member states have developed a
tracing app
or are developing a tracing app the
commission created a european
gateway for interoperability between the
member states
three apps are connected since monday
and during the month of november 19
other ones will
join this european gateway
at the moment being we have
approximately 50 million
downloads concerning smart phone holders
but this is not enough so we need
across-the-board coverage in the
european union
and therefore i asked leaders in each
country to encourage
a massive uptake by citizens so a
massive
download of the app by smartphone
holders
and that we must hook up the apps to our
gateway
so that all apps are communicating and
we have interoperability
all over the european union
and we will bring forward
a passenger locator form in order
to facilitate the tracing during travel
i informed leaders that the commission
will launch a pilot
for the passenger locator form in
november
so our aim is that we
have the passenger locator form on the
european level
by the end of the year and finally the
fifth point indeed
is vaccines and vaccination
we have three priorities here
the first is ensuring validation
of vaccines speedily and we do
have to do the validation at a good pace
while providing all the safety
guarantees
that are necessary so accuracy
and speed at the same time is of the
essence
i highlighted to the leaders that the
european medicines agency
is carrying out a so-called rolling
review of new vaccines
that is that the evidence is being
submitted step by step
by the pharmaceutical companies and it
is being analyzed as it
comes in by emma instead of waiting for
the whole file which is
normally the case you finish the
clinical trial
and then hand in the whole file this
time we're having a
rolling review to speed up the procedure
without
having any shortcuts
the second priority is to ensure indeed
the fair distribution of vaccines
to member states there i have good news
the member states will all get vaccines
at the same time
and at the same conditions based on
their share
of the europe the eu population they
have
and this is already fixed with the
member states who we have already agreed
on that
but thirdly before that before we
really go into the vaccination indeed
the infrastructure for vaccination must
be ready
and this is why we ask the member states
to send in their national vaccination
plans
to make sure that they are all fit for
purpose
to conclude i want to stress
that i understand how tired and worried
everyone is we are wondering
when we will come out of this crisis but
now is the time for
patience for determination
and for discipline from all of us from
governments
right down to each of us individually
all the public policies i have described
are important
but the most important thing is to adopt
and
maintain the right safety habits for
ourselves for our loved ones
for our friends and for our colleagues
wear a mask avoid crowds
avoid close contacts and avoid
closed spaces with poor ventilation that
is key simply doing this
will enormously help in our efforts
and that way all together we will
overcome the virus
thank you i
would like also to mention turkey
because we mentioned
turkey today and as you know we had in
october a strategy debate on the eastern
literature and relationship with turkey
we expressed our determination to be
respected
and to agree to work on two tracks a
positive track
and a less positive one we offered a
clear way to work towards opposite
agenda to 30.
so far turkey has not chosen this path
and we condemn the recent intellectual
action in the eastern mediterranean
provocations and rhetoric which are
completely
unacceptable we will have the attention
to revert to this topic
in december thank you to both presidents
uh we'll now take a couple of questions
i see many hands raised please
switch on your cameras i'm going to
start first with carolina meta basil
carolina you have the floor
thank you for taking my boy
myself double i hope can you give me
twice as well
i don't know we're hearing you perfectly
just lower your volume a little bit
i will this is the question for mrs
fondeline
during the course of this pandemic your
commission has already given out several
guidelines and recommendations
to member states to help them better
coordinate during this crisis
do you wish eu leaders were quicker in
following up
on your recommendations and implementing
implementing those
recommendations and the second question
if i may are you worried that member
states
will again close borders and if not for
goods in the common market than for
individual european travel what was the
beginning of your second question please
the second question was that you were
worried that member states will
start closing borders again not only for
goods but also for
for individual europeans who might want
to cross borders
thank you so um to start with uh
the second part of your questions i
think um
we have all learned the lessons of the
spring so i remember very well in the
spring when at the beginning
most member states looked inward and
closed
borders and it took a little very little
time
to understand that this is hampering
very severely the single market
the flow of goods and therefore not at
all the appropriate
reaction it did not stop the spread of
the virus
so this time you see that we've learned
the lesson
and you see that the approach is way
more differentiated
to fight the virus we've learned how to
deal
with the pandemic and for sure there was
a lot of support
today for the green lanes that have been
established
we announced that we will extend the
green lanes not only for roads but also
for
air waterborne fright and rail
this has been a very good step forward
the green lanes
to really protect our single market and
this is very important
for our member states um the
second or the first part of your
question
here too we have seen a learning process
that by now
member states ask for the recommendation
we work on them
deliver them and in a very timely manner
than
they are implemented in the member
states we have to understand
that in the health topic
the competences are with the member
states so it is a classical approach to
have these recommendations
then to have them implemented in the
member states
i think that the regular information we
have at the leaders level
are very helpful to have a coherent flow
of information
too so if we proceed
this way i'm very satisfied with the
situation
important
questions
thank you moving now to daniel weber
daniel webber radio song
yes i'm here thank you thank you very
much for the floor
my question i i have two short questions
the first one is on the passenger
allocator form
um mrs van der ley and you said that the
commission will launch a pilot and that
the form should be ready by the end of
the year
so my question is what are the
difficulties
to get ready with this form why
does it take so long that's my first
question and the second question is
on vaccines and the commission already
um presented a strategy on that
what was the feedback today of the
member states will they follow this
strategy um yeah what was the feedback
thank you very much yes so
um there are currently 11 member states
that
have already developed a digital
passenger locator forum um at national
level
and they are not interoperable so they
are non-common standard
uh and uncoordinated and of course if
it's
supporting travel necessary travel at
the moment being
but then it should go across border and
all over the european union
therefore the pilot is on connecting
those existing but of course encouraging
the other member states also to come up
with their plf it's a decentralized
approach that is very important because
that has a lot of trust we
made good experience with a decent
centralized approach
with the tracing apps
it is very important that we have the
passenger locator form
not at the moment so much because we do
not encourage
travel but um when things get better
and necessary trap trouble is being
picked up again
then it's it is extremely important
after the experience in summer
that we can track and trace the
different
uh persons if there is an infection that
is taking place
and your second question concerning the
vaccines
here indeed it was very well received
first of all that we provided a
blueprint
for a vaccination strategy so
whom who should be vaccinated first what
group
healthcare workers the elderly
comorbidity
the commission with scientific advice
has put forward a blueprint
but now we are asking the member states
to implement that
in the member states and this was very
well received
the second point is that
member states were eager to hear
where we are at with the coverage of
options for vaccines here
we have contracts with three companies
we are about to have company
contracts with another three companies
and are in good
talk with a seventh one
so this would cover basically the
european
market the production in the european
market and here for member states was
important
to have the reassurance that we have a
fair distribution system in place
already and that they get at the same
time and at the same conditions
the vaccines and indeed the
important point is then the third topic
the
infrastructure they have to build up now
vaccines will come step by step if i may
say so so
we do not know which will be the first
one
and we do not know at the moment being
how successful books vaccines will be
in other words how much immunization
they
they're
able to provide whether it's 50 or 70
percent or up to 90 percent
and therefore we have to keep in mind
that it is a stepwise approach to
immunity
that we will experience with the
vaccines and this was a broad topic
tonight too
thank you passing the floor now to um
andrei matishak from pravda
you have the flow yeah thank you
and good evening um andrey matshek
slovakia david
my question would be for president
mitchell and
i would like to ask you uh slovak prime
minister mr matovich
said that
that he will brief readers
about slovak experiment using nationwide
antigen testing so could you please uh
describe this intervention
maybe that is if there was any
discussion about it
and if any country said that they would
like to follow slovakia
example thank you in
indeed the the prime minister explained
what's the strategy in his country
regarding the the rapid test
and indeed in many countries there is
an interest for the rapid test because
we have the impression
that with the pcr test those
new rapid tests and that's why we are in
further of a mutual recognition
can help in order to develop a global
strategy
ursula van der leyen just explained how
important it was and it is and it will
be
to develop a strong strategy regarding
the vaccines
but we know that the vaccines will not
solve everything
immediately we will need in parallel to
be more efficient
with the testing with the tracing and
uh the prime minister explained that he
will share with all the colleagues with
all the members
the outcome the results of his
strategy and his project
to organize on a very broad basis
testing in order to be able to isolate
and in order to share with us
after that the data in order to to share
different experiences and to to try to
make
more progress everywhere in europe
thank you we'll take a last question
from naomi o'leary
naomi from the irish times
hi thank you very much for taking my
question um so
just for the commission and president of
underlying you said that you don't
encourage travel now
um and that it's very important that
testing and tracing should be in place
for when things get better in hindsight
was it a mistake to encourage the
resumption of tourism in your
reopen eu plan um
given that we can now see through for
example
genetic examination of the strains of
kovic 19
that travel between states fueled the
resurgence that we're seeing now was
that a short-term economic
um policy in the uh now the in hindsight
thanks
so i have not understood all the parts
of the question but
i have understood that it's about
the uh travel and the question whether
it is appropriate or not unnecessary
travel of course is inappropriate
in the situation we're in at the moment
being
it should be reduced to really necessary
essential travel
and you asked for uh
how do we well how would we judge on the
situation looking back
so what we've seen and what we've
learned is
that after the decrees of the first wave
during summer we obviously
have relaxed some measures
too rapidly and
it is not only a question of travel for
sure not
because you've seen in the whole
discussion we had over the last weeks
but also
tonight that there are many variables
that are crucial for keeping
the virus down and what we have to
keep in mind is that we will have to
fight the virus and we will have to keep
the spread of the virus
low till we have enough immunity through
vaccination
in the population so we'll have to be
very careful with
lifting measures and keep in mind the
most
powerful instrument we have in our mind
in our hands
is how we behave ourselves this is masks
this is social distancing and this is
do not stay in closed rooms with poor
ventilation those three things
are of utmost importance to help to keep
the virus down
thank you madam president this concludes
our press conference for tonight and
see you soon thanks for joining
indeed the mask
[Music]
you